one couple that were
coming up with their names were about
their marriage or users like but if they
used to use hard they used to use heroin
and and Coke so
they were like they've probably been
injected since they're like 30 or 14 but
they were young man they're literally
been like hard users they don't go to
school or nothing they just want to
shoot all day
[Music]
I grew up in um barking up until I was
about 10 I left for secondary school
took a live in Essex which was a
Chelmsford yeah I thought after
Secondary School towards the end got
involved with some wrong people and they
kind of just escalate from there
and what about you know the area that
you moved to what sort of area was that
right now it is just like there's a bus
every hour
and chance was pretty much a retirement
series quite old people there there
wasn't a lot of black people around me I
thought that kind of just gave me like a
boosted ego where obviously just acts a
bit outlandish with things in it just
because I was the only kid there that
was a different color and I just feel
like kind of personally to have that
Narrative of Being Alive Kid I thought I
ended time I don't really have much Role
Models I don't speak to my dad so I
don't have a father figure to kind of
lead me the way to show me that yo this
is not the right thing to do as a man
but yeah I don't feel like I have much I
feel like if I had any role models with
the wrong people that was showing me the
wrong ways of living we start going to
parties with older people and they start
doing different drug rather than just
smoking weed and drinking alcohol start
popping pills and stuff and doing that
kit and stuff like that and I feel like
from then
the people that were selling are always
good friends with and that's so we just
kind of grew and start setting up with
them
and from then like we just moved on we
got involved with some people that were
selling hard food probably about year
nine it was just like in school new in
us food I want to go to like here 10 11
so now I really started bringing that
outside of school where kind of was a
thing that we used to start saying we
didn't decide start making money off
without getting involved with other
local little weed Setters out the same
age as us having little tear-ups and
that and like which meant for me to
start selling clothes start selling
pills and that at parties then we went
on to that certain hard field where we
kind of like got involved with this one
guy telling us to go out to Brighton and
different places so he went I think it
was like 15 14. do you mind explaining
exactly what character lines up like
it's pretty much just like for me I was
like a runner
so I wasn't really like the main guy but
it should be taking food
from different places say like the guys
in London would take a few from London
go Brighton and then we'll set up
shopping like some guy's house or we
have someone somewhere to stay
and we start selling from there like the
land was already built so it was just a
matter of answering the phone and going
to meet these people and I feel like I
just kind of took the risk because money
was coming in and I was quite young as
well so kind of just feeding my
addiction as well without smoking weed
and going out so
how is it distributed between like you
and your friends and like how that work
like where we met the guy
we met him in like chance for dinner so
we knew him from Chelsea but he was from
London so we used to go London we used
to grab the food of him and laugh
I don't have to explain it you know what
like we used to go on the train that
concealer
and we would get to the place where he
tell us to go and be like oh there's a
there's a user's yard that you're going
to or there's a skills you are that
you're gonna go to go there and then we
would like organize the food and like
back it up split up and
to disappear from there
and if if anything happened we'll have
to just set up a new house or go to a
new user giving us a future to let us
stay in his house within that or shut
out his house until we move what type of
drugs is it that you know can you learn
it was a crack in heroin so hard food
pretty much is what you call it in there
what sort of money would you say that
you were making then uh I said that
probably the best week has like a runner
album like two grand in a week it wasn't
really a thing where I was smart enough
to save no money or use it properly I
was just literally using it to feed an
addiction at the time
you just feel the lifestyle I shouldn't
really been living
do you know what sort of money a person
above you was making that your supplier
whatever I made you made seven times off
because whoever pack our sold I got 100
out of it he got 700 back so whoever
that he was getting the food for I don't
know what he got the food for say he got
it for life um 200 pound per 80 bit pack
he probably made like 600 700 per pack
so you'd probably be making like five
five six times more than being profit
how did he treat you was all right to be
fair like a lot of a lot a lot of the
times where I went dealing with another
people as well I got treated value but I
was only there for like a few times I
left because
the
the comparison between me and Brian and
me and this other place where I was his
insurance but I said all these other
people for a bit I just left because
this man just tried bumped me they're
structuring your bird they used to try
to pay me and like weed and stuff and
try to treat him as a girly because I
was young but it never really treated me
bad like that he it wasn't it wasn't it
was it wasn't it wasn't a bad person I
thought it was just involved in that he
used to pay us right
used to show us how to do it as well so
yeah he went really that bad in it you
get worse people than him and the sort
of people that you were selling to uh
when you're in Brighton what what were
they like just she uses particularly
Fair those Jesus whatever you sold to
other people that I never thought other
dealers or was high enough to sell this
other dealers but it was just over using
it we sold to users all ages managed to
sold to people that were like 19 20 uses
people that like 70 60 years and so one
couple that were um
come up with their names are about they
were like seven or 16 both of them they
were like my age and I'm used to chill
with them sometimes we smoked Zeus with
them but they'll manage their users like
but if they used to use hard disease
heroin and encode so
they were like they probably been
injected since July 30 or 14 but
they were young man they're literally
been like hard users they don't go to
school or nothing they just want to
shoot all day they were like girlfriend
and boyfriend but they were my age at
the time like so
that hit that hit quite close
let's talk about um
your mum and like your family you have
communication with her yeah I was very
distant to my mom I got a lot of missing
persons filed for me because so now I'll
be gone for like a week and a half and
I'll come back to the police will just
leave the whole into the investigation
when I come back but I happen quite a
lot a few times I thought I went missing
like four or three times and police were
always on my door they always try to
find me
police were going to like my
ex-girlfriend's houses and that and um
yeah I thought I was quite distant from
my mum I kind of just ignored everything
she said to me and I just pushed her at
that equation because she I feel like
she was the only person that held on for
a long time trying to get me out of this
life and shows she said to me as well
that
a point she never saw me coming back she
thought that I'd be stuck in that life
for good if she's still trying she's
still trying to call me still following
reports on that how long were you
actually spending in brown two weeks a
week most of the time I come back and
like but the thing is I'd come back and
go back to my friend's house I wouldn't
go home but I'd be gone for like a month
or less than a month from home so I'll
go to my friend's house maybe come home
for like a day or so sometimes my mom
wouldn't be in should be working and I
just believe it leave again so
yeah those times my mom didn't see me
for like three weeks most of the time I
thought I was very shallow back then
I feel like now it makes you sad to me
like to think that I made my Mumford
would have it for so long but at the
time to be honest I didn't really care
you had run-ins with the police right
yeah the dad got arrested was when I
changed the area was in like the strip
area was in was very hot so we like
moved from like three yards in the same
in the same week so there was a lot of
police around there was a lot of meat
wagons like big police trucks so I
thought they kind of really close to us
but at the time I just kind of brushed
it I just kept on moving houses
so it got to a point where I moved to
this um one one user's house
and when I've gone out to I'm gonna I've
gone out to go back to London actually
I've run out of um I ran out of food I
ran out of dark and I hardly had light
on me so I was gonna go back to London
to get more food off my supplier and
I've come out the yard and there was
like police everywhere like there was
police on the roads there was police on
bikes and I tried to cycle out and run
away but I got cool obviously and I got
taken to sales for that day
how did it how did that feel sort of
when you were when you were in the South
um
I feel like kind of when I first got
arrested initially it kind of kind of
hit me because I hadn't I didn't have
anything concealed I had everything on
me that could have got me jeopardized or
put me in jail so
I knew that at the time I was I was cool
red-handed in it so in sales when I was
waiting to be searched um
yeah I was stressed or I just all I
could think about is what's my family
gonna think what's my mom gonna think
because my mom didn't actually know that
I was like
so
she found out after I got arrested
did you call her when you were in that
yeah they talk they asked me to call my
mom because I was under 18 so I had to
call my mom to get my mom to what did
she say when you called her I'm not sure
remember to be fair but I just remember
being like proper stressed maybe I
remember a phone call and you sweat a
lot so I was stressed out at the time
what was it that you were charged with
um I got charged killing my basis for
intense Supply
so I didn't get any jail time I got put
on tag for a year
um I got arrested for having a bladed
dark cool well arrested for robbery as
well but it was only like a minor one
where I just stole some clothes with
some guy
and it was like in another assault as
well but this was something completely
different so I had all these at the same
time that I was going to court for
I don't know so I saw my cousin Gojo at
the time as well for the same thing and
he's gone to jail for like 20 years now
so I was thinking it's not worth it like
it's quick money it's not worth it as
soon as I got a job I'm going jail for
like seven years so it's gonna
completely just even out I'm gonna make
zero pounds in jail do I mean so
seven years it's gonna be
it's going to add up to a normal wage if
I if I just live a normal lifetime you
know get my get my qualifications and
live a comfortable life rather than
having to look over my back all the time
and spend time in jail because I didn't
put anyone's name down I didn't get
anyone in trouble for what I did so kind
of let me push away without no
repercussions you know what I mean I
know there's a lot of other kids in
different situations where they've
they're not being stupid about it but
they've got out by snitching on the
people that they work with and and they
get like maybe stabbed or get like um
threats made towards them so yeah it was
difficult the fact that I lost a lot of
friends all the friends I was with for
that whole time I was friends with for a
long time and I friends with since I was
like early teens I completely lost
friendship with them don't speak to them
no more
and shortly after I found out both of
them my mates they went chill so
it wasn't the fact that I could even
speak to them so yeah
and the tag get restricted you to stay
in what area Essex so I was allowed to I
wasn't allowed to go London I wasn't
allowed to live anywhere up in Essex and
I'd have to um
speak to my parole officer if I want to
go to any if I wanted to go anywhere
more than 30 miles out from my house
right um curfew was nine o'clock so it
wasn't too bad but I couldn't stare
after night or anything I couldn't go
out and do things around me I was
located every single second on my life
for the time I was on it and I kind of
learned quite a lot of my proof so it
was really nice to be fair like he was a
good person he wasn't one of those guys
that trying to die me by telling me
about letting me tell him information
and get me done for it he was generally
trying to help me and I feel like I
built a trust with him over time and I
thought I kind of opened up to him quite
a lot and he showed me like what I was
doing wasn't really helping and I
thought he opened my eyes to be fair
and in terms of like what you focus on
now just posting really I just finished
College I thought my level four and
engineering not really a fan of it so
I'm going back to UNI next year and I
want to go be doing computer science so
I've got to do like axis here so I would
be there for like four years but right
now she's boxing the train a lot so
the main thing I focused on is boxing I
feel like my mom was
probably the least person to to put
consequences on me at the sense that
kind of understood that
what I was doing I got addicted to and
she was kind of kind of soft to me on it
to be fair but
she just made sure that I was safe and
she got CCTV around the house and that
because she was a bit praying that
anyone would come back and
and try to do me away before
leaving leaving I saw a lifestyle I'm
close to my mom I've always been closing
my mom but I kind of pushed her away for
the time of the time when I was out
there selling drugs but yeah my mom's my
best friend my mom I've always been so
close to my mom I was totally a person I
really hope that's like my intermediate
family
what sort of regrets do you have then
when you look back as well
it's the way I treat people I feel that
way I treat people in the way I was
I've had a lot of hate at the time I was
a very hateful person at the time
to put it that's not my mind you regret
being so hateful and sort of shallow
towards the people that actually care
about me but
to come along with it being around that
every day
for that each push yourself into our
mindset to act like that
where do you think that stemmed from now
I don't know really I could have been
stemming from smoking weed all the time
not doing anything positive being around
bad people all the time I feel like that
might have been there I only know to be
fair but I should know that the time
that I don't really have much love in my
heart I was a very hateful person
towards a lot of people the only really
times I was really happy it was like I
was just chilling out my few friends and
that and going out but really we did
that I mean
when you look back obviously though you
were young
do you feel like you were taken
advantage of at all
I feel like I wasn't taking advantage of
that in the fact that I was a clean
slave I mean I was easy to brainwash I
thought it was more of addiction I feel
like they led me into an addiction
rather than me being brainwashed
so I feel like yeah I was taking
advantage of I was I was taking
advantage of the Sinister they made me
addicted to what I was doing
I don't really look at it as me being
scared I was never really scared in the
sense but I feel like I was kind of
naive to the whole thing you know I mean
I just wanted to make money at the time
and getting out in the way I did I got
very lucky that so
yeah I feel like it's opened my eyes and
just kind of kept me kept me well
behaved and just keep me striving to my
goals because I know that
anything can really happen
for the one thing is as well a lot of
young kids are out here selling rather
than the people that are actually
running because as much it's really easy
to
to brainwash a clean slate you know I
mean he's just her brain with your kids
and rather than a man
so as I reloaded and went pointing the
gun I is when he jumped in the back of
the van but I ran to the passenger side
and then shot through the passenger side
window